now what we're going to do is we're
going to move from just straight here's
a random triangle in the middle of
nowhere
that has random lengths and random
angles on it we're going to go towards
what we call applications
of trigonometry so you can see this
question is all clothed in practical
language and in fact a big part of this
it's why you can see nothing on my board
um and you're gonna need to have like a
fresh space to do this question is
um a big part of this question is
interpreting reading understanding what
it means
and then translating into the
mathematics let's read it together
uh lenny drives 120 kilometers on a
bearing of
and then you see this this is the first
roadblock right if you haven't done
bearings for a little while there's
generally two ways to represent bearings
this one what's the t stand for true
right um sometimes also called three
figure bearings but
i think true is a more helpful way to
say it um a true bearing pick out your
pen
a true bearing is measured from where if
i drew like a little compass here
where do i measure from yeah from north
so let's go ahead on your little compass
there let's start by
having north in there so we measure from
true north
hence the you know the fact that it's
called true bearings
this time it's 130 degrees so when we
start from here
um i guess the next question is do we go
um
rotating to the left or rotating to the
right to the right we're going to go
clockwise okay
so 130 degrees you can see it takes us
past that right angle
it takes us kind of facing in that
direction does that make sense so if i
were to
go around from here i hit 90 degrees and
then i'm going to go
further 130 is like it's close to half
way
between these two bottom right
parts of the compass is that a great so
i'm going to have something that looks a
bit like
that that's going to head off and then
that gives me this line i'm going to
draw shortly
which will be at 130 degrees
true okay so there's the first piece of
information
what comes next um well actually uh i
should probably go back
now i've got a direction i can do my 120
kilometers so let's go ahead and put in
i might use a different color for this
one and if you've got a different color
that'll be helpful too
i'm going to put in where she actually
drives
and that was 120 kilometers according to
the question
now i'm ready to go into the next
sentence she goes which direction
she drives west so i always think about
western australia that's how i
remembered which you could do northeast
you know never exaggerated whatever
works for you so she's going to drive
west i guess if i drew another little
you know compass here you can see me
going to the left
how far does she go have a look at the
question
until she is south of her starting point
so here's the starting point up here
so south is down here so i guess what i
could do
is extend that first compass that i drew
i'm going to go down like so
and you can see i'm going to collide
with this due south line right so i'm
coming back to my
original color i'm going to go
off in the westward direction okay
so this is her journey and because she
traveled west and she hit this line
that's
due south what can you tell me about
this dotted line and this
part of the journey there at right
angles perpendicular so that's handy all
the knowledge we've got from the
previous
set of questions will help us here how
far is she from her starting point
correct to the nearest
kilometer so i'm going to put a
pronumeral on here to help me
um where is the premium going to go
you can point to it right it's going to
be yeah can you tell me how would you
describe it verbally
[Music]
yeah sounds at a starting point i guess
i could draw this like solid black line
here now yeah
and i guess you know pretty unoriginal
let's call it like x
for the unknown and it's a length of
kilometers right so that's what i'm
after
okay wonderful so now i've set up the
question
now i just need to make sure i use the
trigonometry knowledge i have
appropriately right
now i've got some lengths here in this
triangle but what's sneaky about this
question
what's problematic that i need to do a
little bit of extra work before i can do
any trigonometry
here go ahead
yeah i need some angles on the inside of
this i've got the 90 but that's
it's always a right angle triangle that
i'm getting in these kinds of questions
i don't have either of these angles but
i
can work it out right which one's easier
to work out
this one in here right i guess would be
fine that whole angle there is a
straight angle so it adds up to
180 so the missing acute angle is going
to be
50. let's go ahead and mark that in
there
right at this point i've now turned this
sort of um
worded question here which is a bit less
familiar into something completely
familiar this is
exactly like all the questions we've
been doing recently so how
are we going to set it up can someone
give me a suggestion what's the first
thing i'm going to write
i have a thing all right so i've got
i've got an angle in here i've got one
angle
and then i look at these two sides over
here which one's known and one's unknown
right
adjacent to 50 degrees hypotenuse
so this is going to be cosine so i'm
going to write down cos
of 50 degrees
equals what
adjacent on hypotenuse yeah
so there's just one extra step here to
make sure i'm clear
i just want the x by itself so i'm going
to multiply both sides through by 120.
i think that is a really helpful uh line
to have
and then at this point it's calculated
work yeah so x is going to be equal to
who's going to get there first someone
already got it
[Applause]
one three four dot dot dot the question
itself has asked us to get it to the
nearest
kilometer so i'm going to put a last
line for approximation
77 um kilometers
to the nearest unit in this case you're
happy with that
any questions on how we set that up um
just as an interesting exercise of
course you can work out this other
angle in here um to be 40.
and i guess if that was the one that we
worked out what would we we would use a
different ratio all together wouldn't we
we wouldn't use cos what would we use
opposite or hypothesis is going to give
me sine so sine of 40 degrees should be
x on 120 and then off you go okay
i promised two examples let's have a
look at this one
okay oh wait no sorry i tell a lie
before we go to this one
i said there were two ways to describe
angles
um in variance questions like this right
we looked at one which was true bearings
if for example you were writing this
question and you didn't want to write
130 degrees true how else could you
describe this direction that eleni
travels in the first place there's
another way to do it
not with true bearings any takers
hmm it's quite tricky um to think back
right
the other way we would sort of describe
this is in relation to our north south
east west right so we would say oh you
know to get around to here it's between
between south and east do you agree it's
between south
and east so where you could describe
this same angle
you know which direction you're
traveling in is it's somewhere between
south
and east how far is it between south
and east it's this angle here right you
start it south and you wind how far
towards east
50 degrees so we could call this south
50 degrees east right does that make
sense why don't we start with east and
then go to south
for absolutely no particular reason to
be honest this is just the convention
in much the same way as it's just a
convention to start from north you could
start from anywhere else if you wanted
but this is just what we all
agreed upon okay so if you see this same
thing you just need to be able to
interpret that and you'll see that come
up in the exercise
okay four minutes are gonna be enough
let's do this one quick smile
this is not about bearings anymore we're
gonna need to draw a new diagram for
this
read it with me and help me out about
200 meters out to sea
from a vertical cliff of height 40
meters so we've got a lot of information
right there
okay the first thing i'm probably going
to draw is the cliff
cliff is 40 meters
and it's vertical looks good to me and
then it says
the boat is 200 meters out to sea so
where is this going to go now where am i
going to draw 200 meters
yeah it's going to be horizontal it's
sort of off in this rightward direction
okay
so i'm gonna go ahead and chuck in
at 200 meters there's my boat you're
happy with that
it then says find the angle of
depression so just like in the previous
question
a lot of what we are asked to do is tied
up in language right
so you're going to meet angles of
elevation and angles of depression
where are angles of elevation and
depression measured
from any takers what do you reckon
angle of elevation is looking down
up and down up yeah
yep yep angle of depression is when
you're working down okay good so there's
a lot of like positional language in
there
we've got an angle of depression here so
as you just stated
it's looking down towards the boat
right but where it's measured from is
well if you weren't looking down where
would you be looking
and the answer is off to the horizon
which is horizontal
okay so this particular angle of
depression is how
far down do i have to look so in this
particular diagram
our angle of depression would be here
okay so i'm going to write that in even
i'm going to label it as angle
of depression and
it's worth jotting down that both angles
of elevation and depression are
from the horizontal
so that's what it is and where it is
what's the actual angle i can't even
remember
oh that's what we're trying to find
that's what we're trying to find so
should we give it a name what would like
to call it
i think i heard a theta that'll do okay
so that's what i'm trying
to find um worth mentioning angles of
elevation if we went from the boat
looking up right again it's from the
horizontal which in this case would be
along the water line and then we're
looking
up okay so we've got again
sides we've got an angle up here
but just like with our bearings question
part of the challenge is
the angle you get provided is not inside
the triangle so how do i get it
from the outside to the interior
of the triangle there's some knowledge
that we learned back in year 78 that
might help us yeah
it's the same value than the
corner okay so there's a few corners
which corner are you talking about
the boat corner okay so down here i can
call this theta as well but it's
actually quite important that we say why
it's because these two angles here they
form this
what's a backwards looking z right what
kind of angles are those
they're alternate angles that's because
we've got a horizontal and another
horizontal
right so it's actually worth mentioning
right the horizontal lines
are parallel because by definition
they're horizontal right so since
they're parallel i can use all the stuff
that i know about parallel lines
alternate angles in this case if i had
corresponding angles or co-interior or
whatever right
the whole point is it gets an angle from
the outside of the triangle
to the inside we're ready to write an
equation
with a trigonometric ratio we'll do this
real quick what ratio
am i going to use it's 10 because
opposite
on adjacent relative to this particular
angle so you said 10
that's going to be 40
over 200 okay so at this point i can
just do a teeny bit of simplifying but
mostly
the calculator is going to do the work
isn't it right can someone go ahead and
tell me what
theta is equal to give me some decimal
places as well
eleven point three zero nine nine dot
dot dot and the actual accuracy they
want
is to the nearest
degree so i don't even need to go to
degrees minutes seconds to do that
approximation right
this is going to go straight to 11 and
i'm good